ah le plaisir on aimerait qu'ils durent
toujours plus longtemps qui ne s'arrête
jamais on aimerait qu'elle soit toujours
plus fort plus intense on se dit même
que l'excès de plaisir ça peut pas faire
de mal et pourtant la réalité c'est que
très souvent
l'excès de plaisir conduit au déplaisir
plaisir plaisir plaisir plaisir plaisir
plaisir plaisir
comment savoir comment l'ex et le
plaisir peut engendrer le déplaisir
aller blague à part trop de plaisir peut
réellement tué le plaisir et même
devenir une source de déplaisir et de
souffrance c'est ce qui se passe dans le
cas des addictions ou le plaisir
initiale très un temps de la drogue et
cède rapidement la place au déplaisir au
déplaisir du manque au déplaisir de la
dépendance ou des plaisirs de la perte
de contrôle
[Musique]
quand le plaisir devient trop intense
trop fréquents trop rapide trop facile
il ouvre grande ouverte la porte à la
diction et à tous et des plaisirs
c'est pourquoi dans notre société où les
sources de plaisirs n'ont pas cessé de
se multiplier et de s'intensifier des
addictions se sont également multipliés
certains parlent même de société
addictogène alors je suis sûr que vous
avez tous entendu beaucoup parler des
addictions droit langues comme par
exemple l'addiction à l'héroïne ou à la
cocaïne ou encore à l'alcool
[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous parler d'une autre
addiction
c'est une addiction assez méconnu à une
substance pourtant archi connus qui est
partout présente et notamment dans nos
assiettes
je veux parler du sucre alors pendant
très longtemps le sucre a été une source
de plaisir autant agréable qu'elle était
rare aujourd'hui la sur consommation de
sucre est devenu une source de déplaisir
pour beaucoup d'entre nous comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là
alors pour essayer de comprendre
nous allons tous ensemble faire un
voyage dans le temps
nous allons remonter dans le passé de
notre espèce juste un tout petit retour
en arrière
allez seulement de 40 des membres au
moins sa pièce découvre l'europe et ses
forêts où il va rechercher refuse
également sa nourriture
en ces temps préhistoriques rechercher
sa nourriture n'était pas chose facile
contrairement à ce que certains ont pu
l'imaginer
ce n'était pas le paradis il n'y avait
ni rivière de miel ni fontaine à soda
les calottes glaciaires de l'époque
n'était ni à la fraise ni au chocolat en
fait rechercher sa nourriture
à cette époque était même plutôt
dangereux à cause des bêtes sauvages et
des prédateurs cachés dans la forêt les
plantes elles mêmes étaient peu
nutritifs c'était bien avant leur
domestication réservant l'agriculture
elle pouvait même être dangereuse car
elle était très toxique
vous l'aurez compris à cette époque
rechercher sa nourriture et manger
pouvait être pendant n'était pas simple
et pouvait être même risqué allez ne
nous attardons pas plus longtemps dans
le passé et revenons au présent en
france
waouh que le monde a changé les
supermarchés ont remplacé les forêts
prix historique le premier supermarché a
ouvert en 1958 et aujourd'hui ils se
comptent pas
nous n'avons pas besoin de partir dans
la forêt pour rechercher notre
nourriture
il suffit d'aller au supermarché et
quand on passe les portes d'un
supermarché une des première chose qui
saute aux yeux c'est l'immensité du
choix à chaque produit alimentaire
correspond une variété presque infinies
il
il y en a pour tous les goûts toutes les
couleurs tous les plaisirs
moi par exemple dans mon supermarché
j'ai pu compter jusqu'à une centaine de
lots différents avec autant de parfums
de couleurs de textures darron
différents en fait tout est fait pour
attiser le désir pour stimuler l'envi et
au final bien sûr pour maximiser le
plaisir
alors même si parfois on éprouve un peu
d'embarras bhl et voire même du vertige
face à tant de joie dans un supermarché
aujourd'hui la recherche de nourriture
est devenue avant tout une recherche de
plaisir
la nourriture elle même est devenue
avant tout plaisir
pour paraphraser molière dans l'avare
nous ne mangeons plus pour vivre nous
vivons pour manger pour le plaisir de
manger
sérieusement qui aujourd'hui échangerait
sa place avec celle de chasseurs que
l'homme préhistorique
mais ce tableau est idyllique en
apparence derrière lui se cache une
autre réalité moins reluisante la
liberté dont nous semblons jouir dans un
supermarché est un leurre
l'immensité du choix est une illusion en
fait dans un supermarché type trois
quarts des produits alimentaires
fabriqués contiennent du sucre
essentiellement des sucres rapides tels
que par exemple le saccharose
juste pour vous donner un chiffre chaque
année en produits trente mille milliards
de morceaux de sucre notre monde notre
univers alimente
et c'est édulcoré il est très difficile
aujourd'hui des châteaux sucre au final
dans un supermarché
nous avons surtout le choix entre l'udc
et du sucre alors dès le début du 19e
siècle le grand romancier honoré de
balzac s'inquiétait déjà de cette
édulcoration et pourtant à son époque
ses contemporains ne consommer que 2 kg
de sucre par an alors qu'aujourd'hui un
français moyen on consomme plus de 30 kg
c'est à dire quinze fois plus
[Musique]
le problème c'est que cette
surconsommation de sucre n'est pas
essentiel on peut très bien vivre en
bonne santé sans sucre alors bien sûr
notre organisme a besoin de glucose pour
fonctionner normalement
mais l'équipe est biologiquement pour
l'obtenir autrement à partir d'une
alimentation dent sucrée
non seulement cette surconsommation de
sucre n'est pas essentiel mais elle peut
même devenir néfaste pour la santé
nous savons aujourd'hui que le suc est
un facteur déterminant dans le surpoids
l'obésité
juste pour rappel en france aujourd'hui
il y à 7 millions de personnes obèses et
le surpoids et l'obésité à leur tour
augmente le risque de développer des
maladies chroniques telles que par
exemple le diabète qui touche
aujourd'hui 4 millions de français et ce
chiffre est en augmentation
il faut se rendre à l'évidence notre
corps n'est pas armé pour faire face à
cette amélioration du monde et ce pour
une raison assez simple en fait
au cours de la grande transformation qui
nous a conduit des forêts préhistorique
au supermarché en fait une seule chose a
très peu changé
c'est ni homo sapiens en effet à
l'échelle de l'évolution quarante mille
ans est un très court instant
résultat notre biologie est en décalage
avec le nouvel environnement édulcoré
que nous habitants c'est ce qui explique
notre
habilité alors pourquoi cette aide le
corps à sion comme toujours il ya
plusieurs explications
le sucre possède de nombreuses
propriétés qui le rendent intéressant
aux yeux des industriels de
l'alimentation
c'est un agent conservateur il peut
améliorer la texture de certains
aliments m m en favoriser la crise on
met le sucre possède une autre propriété
c'est une substances addictives rajouter
du sud dans un produit est le moyen le
plus simple et le plus efficace
d'accrocher le consommateur et de le
pousser à surconsommer
malgré les conséquences négatives
encore une fois c'est honoré de balzac
qui fut le premier à s'inquiéter de
l'addiction au sucre et cette idée a
malheureusement été et est resté pendant
longtemps ignoré jusqu'à ce que dans les
années 2000 elle refait surface et ce en
grande partie suite à une découverte
réalisée par hasard dans notre
laboratoire ici à bordeaux
alors je me souviens très bien
à cette époque nous venions de découvrir
chez des rats de laboratoire que nous
les chercheurs l'utilisant comme des
sortes de modèles réduits de l'être
humain et à qui on peut apprendre à
s'auto injecter des drogues que
l'addiction à la cocaïne modifient
durablement le cerveau et notamment le
circuit nominale de la récompense vous
savez ce circuit qui est enfoui dans le
cerveau de tous les mammifères et qui
nous pousse à les rechercher à répéter
les sensations qui nous ont procuré du
plaisir cours de l'une de nos
expériences nous avons proposé nos
animaux une boisson sucrée comme une
récompense alternative à la drogue
pensant bien sûr comme tous les
neuroscientifiques de l'époque que les
animaux allaient continuer à prendre
la drogue est ignoré la boisson sucrée
et bien non à notre grande surprise des
animaux se sont détournés rapidement de
la drogue et se soit mis à préférer la
boisson sucrée
cette découverte était tellement
choquant qu'on a refusé d'y croire au
départ
pensant qu on avait peut-être commis une
erreur ou qu'il y avait un vice caché
dans notre expérience
mais après plusieurs années de
vérification et de nombreuses
expériences complémentaires
une seule conclusion a fini par
s'imposer
il n'y a pas photo pour le sucre surface
la cocaïne cette découverte ensuite
était confirmée par d'autres
laboratoires aux quatre coins du monde
et avec d'autres drogues comme par
exemple l'héroïne
bon je suppose qu'à ce stade de ma
présentation vous commencez à vous
demander
ok vos recherches sont certes
intéressantes elles sont même fascinante
mais bon voyons nous ne sommes pas des
rats comment vous pouvez vous permettre
de généraliser votre découverte à
l'homme
et bien sûr vous auriez tout à fait
raison de vous poser cette question très
importante
en fait nous connaissons déjà la réponse
à cette question
suite à notre découverte des études
ultérieures mené chez l'homme on permet
de montrer que l'addiction au sucre
touche 5 à 10% des personnes et que ce
pourcentage augmente chez les personnes
obèses et peut même atteindre 20 %
c'est-à-dire une personne obèse sur cinq
ces chiffres sont comparables aux autres
addictions
par ailleurs nous avons pu visualiser
visualisé par dans le cerveau de ces
personnes des modifications que l'on
retrouve
dans les autres addictions et enfin s'il
fallait un dernier argument pour finir
de vous convaincre de la réalité de
cette addiction
je crois peut-être que le mieux c'est de
donner la parole de jeunes personnes
obèses en trois avec cette addiction
[Musique]
c'est comme une drogue
ceux qui avant me donner du plaisir n'a
plus beaucoup d'effet je me sens comme
immunisée contre le plaisir de manger
alors je bouffe de plus en plus mais
c'est plus aussi bon qu'avant je
continue quand même c'est très bizarre
je crois que je suis addict à la bouffe
j'essaie de manger correctement mais je
m'emballe jusqu à tout dévorer tout ce
qui est beau je sais que je dois arrêter
de trop manger mais j'y arrive pas
sérieux j'essaie de me dire d'arrêter
mais ça ne marche pas je crois que ces
deux témoignages peuvent se passer de
tout commentaire
allez il est temps à présent de conclure
en quittant les forêts préhistorique
nous avons laissé derrière nous notre
peur des prédateurs mais le risque
d'intoxication est lui toujours présent
et il a pris de nouvelles formes
notamment celle de monde édulcoré
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce monde
édulcoré c'est nous qui l'avons créé le
risque peut donc être contrôlé il ne
s'agit pas bien sûr de revenir en
arrière ou de retourner dans la forêt il
ne s'agit pas non plus de bannir ou
d'interdire le sucre il s'agit
simplement de lui redonner une place
mais pas toute la place de manière à ce
que le sucre redevienne un plaisir parmi
d'autres plaisirs
au fond il s'agit de regagner notre
liberté de consommateurs d'avoir à
nouveau le choix et de ne pas être
forcée de choisir entre le sud est de ne
plus être forcé par don de choisir entre
du sucre et du fus
voilà merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]